first of all really
great to see you um so i just before we
get started into why i get to talk to
you today i love
nine days and thank you loved it
and it's been frustrating talking about
a movie that i saw over a year ago
that hasn't come out yet so are you just
like me like just waiting for this thing
to come out
yes you know it was supposed to come out
last year but then obviously
obviously 2020 changed a lot of stuff so
that one's going to come out in january
but then they push it now as far as i
understand it's coming out in
august who knows if that's true or not
but
um yeah it's um you know you saw the
film
i think it's a really special movie that
cat that cass and crew is also very
special to me
it's just a very life-affirming uh you
know positive movie about life and i i'm
looking forward to
eating it yeah i'm glad you feel that
way i'm glad you liked
it yeah i love them yeah i it's real
good um
so everyone i've been interviewing the
last year i asked the same first two
questions
uh uh what tv show series do you want to
guest star on
ooh i'm watching fleabag right now
it's a really good show i'd love to be
homeless
um and i know i'm i'm late to that game
i suppose
uh and um yeah i guess that's my answer
sure what movie or movies do you think
you've seen the most
um in my life or in the last
year oh like in your life we're talking
in my life oh
that's easy um sound of music singing in
the rain
bridesmaids pride and prejudice
sure uh jumping into why i get to talk
to you
saw the first three episodes of
invincible and the best compliment i can
give it is that if i had had access to
more episodes i would have continued
watching
like immediately um so i'm just curious
the voice cast that they got for this
show is
ridiculous was it one of these things
where either a they slid you an extra
five dollars
or b was it that uh they offered you
like a close-up zombie roll and walking
dead like how did this cast come
together
you know what i don't know i was one of
the last people i think to get the call
and the cast was already there and i was
like yeah obviously i'm doing
this um but i also
you know i don't know honestly the
writing kind of speaks for itself like
uh robert is great at what he does and
um
the reading the pilot uh you know it's
just a really engaging story and i think
it's super grounded and it feels really
human and
you know i it was an easy
yes for me frankly so um and also the
fact that he was involved in the series
as the creator of the comic that to me
was very
like i felt i felt like it was in good
hands and i trusted that he was very
involved in the whole recording process
and everything so
um you know i knew his voice was going
to be
in the televised version as well so yeah
the cast i think
when people just liked the material once
you've got the role
how much were you sort of like i'm going
to read the comics i'm going to learn
everything there is and how much are you
sort of like you know i would rather
just
you know like how much do you want to
know about everything and how much do
you want to sort of take it
by season by season um
i i did sort of a bit like so i didn't
like read
all the comics but i definitely like did
some did some research and i
and i read some um i also know
this show is is a bit dif is not the
exact same storyline as the comics it is
a bit different
um you know for me it was more important
to kind of get the
the feel and the vibe and the tone and
then also to get to know some of these
characters
sort of as bass lines um
and so yeah i'm kind of like more
i suppose season by season in a way um
but then also not necessarily expecting
the story lines to completely overlap
either completely what is it i've spoken
to so many different people that work on
different animated shows sometimes
everyone does stuff in a group the way
like they did rango
sometimes it's you know everyone's in a
box by themselves sometimes it's like
they record everything in one day
and other people it could be like two
years of recording so for your journey
on this
how was it uh it was alone
um but relatively quickly so i think the
majority of us i'm assuming kind of
recorded this like spring of 2019
um okay and and
yeah i was on my own you know besides
the director and robert and some
producers who were on the other side of
the glass sort of
giving me guidance um i know some of the
actors i think stephen and jk simmons
and maybe sandra oh i think had an
opportunity to record together like some
people got to do it together
but uh you know i i was on my own um so
yeah you know and it was over it was
over a little bit of time because they
were working on the episodes i'm kind of
doing it like episodically
so i wasn't just whipping out all of my
character
or the whole season um but that is
traditionally
anything i've done animated has kind of
been that
yeah um i what's interesting is like on
what's the there was a
surfs up they did a lot of recording
together and i think that you can sort
of tell
because the dialogue is on top of each
other and
it sort of it's really cool it is i
think it is
i'm surprised i'm sure it just costs
more money i guess but i'm surprised i
don't do that more often because i
really do think you would get a better
um not saying that invisible isn't
amazing but i do think
to have the natural banter you know i
did actually
i am recording something right now where
i'm having the opportunity to
to record via zoom with another one of
the
actors um and yes we're like overlapping
and
the the banter is different and we're
able to feed off of each other's energy
and
obviously when you're not doing that the
directors
uh of or the director of
of an animated series is working with
other people so they know what other
people are doing and they're like oh we
just did this scene this way with
stephen and he said it
like this maybe you can try an option
where you say it like that too
and then sometimes they'll rework a
scene and then they call you back and
being like actually the tone shifted
because this actor did that and so we're
including that and so
you just come in more often and then
re-record essentially
but yeah i think nothing beats like
chemistry yeah you're making me wonder
um
i just spent i just did a two-hour
interview with gore rubinski
and now i'm wondering if you're working
with core because he's doing an animated
movie
oh well i'm not
saying anything right got it
i'm just thinking about that what was
your reaction watching this for the
first time because
i don't want to do spoilers or anything
but it's kind of violent
have you watched the episodes no i
haven't had no
well they haven't sent me the episodes
so um
i haven't seen anything besides the the
teaser
um but they don't really i don't think
people were like they don't
send at like you often have to beg to
see movies like
i'm like there's been so many times like
i really want to see this movie before
the premiere and they're like
we don't know and i'm like no y'all i
need to see this movie um
and so no i haven't they haven't sent me
any episodes um
but you know reading the script the
scripts are actually written very like
visually it's you can definitely um
which makes sense and obviously the
comics you know
you have a sense of what things are
going to look like and he's already
like how death and gore is depicted i
think is a big part of
the show and the visual element of
of the comic and um
i don't know i i like it i think it's i
think it brings
realism um to sort of this heightened
cartoon space and um honestly i find
when i do watch things that have a lot
of death in them i kind of get sometimes
annoyed when it's just like
he died i think i think it's more
interesting to deal with it
uh and i think it adds
more layers and complexity to stories
and obviously
you know there's different spaces for
different things and maybe that's not
always what you need but
um i have to say as a storyteller i
appreciate that a lot
and i think it um makes the characters
more complicated and more
interesting and more human and more
relatable so
um yeah it's it's it's tough being a
superhero
it's like and it's tough being like a
teenager and suddenly being faced with
this great responsibility
and what is that sacrifice what does
that mean what does that mean for trauma
frankly and how that affects your like
interpersonal relationships so
yeah i i think that is special about
invincible
yeah um i also agree that often times in
tv and movies
you know someone dies and then like the
next scene people just forget about the
character
and that's also i think what's different
with invincible is that
like consequences are really real so
like if somebody dies people are
like they don't come back you know what
i mean and and
and i think in a lot of different
versions of stories like you know
there's like other
a different dimension they come back or
like there was a glitch in the blah blah
blah
and then they time travel and they come
back but i feel like here it's sort of
you know what i mean like
it's just sort of like a no that's
that's life
that's the consequence of life uh you
remember at the beginning of the
interview when i said to you what tv
series would you love to guest star on
so i would say a huge percentage of
people
say atlanta oh
really like a lot um especially
especially when it was airing
when i did that question so of course
i'm just going to throw out there as a
huge fan of the series
um where are you are you where are you
in the filming process of season three
and four
so we haven't started it yet but we're
right about to i actually was a i was
actually supposed to have
been traveled to where we're shooting
um
um i i think i can say it i think people
know we're shooting this
um we're shooting this in in europe
because of how some of the storyline
goes um but
that got pushed and so i'm i'm try i'm
traveling march
22nd oh so you're pretty close oh
shoot yeah so
[Music]
anything is the writing is so brilliant
um have you had a chance to
read any of the scripts and what was it
i just got them well i got them like a
week ago and i've read them so
yes it's very good right
uh i want to pre so is there anything
you can tease or
or not i don't i don't think i can
i'm not going to we haven't even had the
conversation yet and so
um nada but i think it's
i don't know it's going to be good i
think i'm very listen
there's no doubt in my mind that i mean
yeah it's such an exceptional show
so i'll switch to something else which
is obviously
uh we're all so excited that um feige
announced that deadpool 3
is going to be in the mcu and uh i'm
just curious in the last year or two
have you
actually spoken to kevin feige about
domino
and deadpool 3 or no
um i haven't you know i i i would love
to revive the role you know i
i think um that was always something you
know
in the world of of what was potentially
going to happen
um but i haven't had any like specific
conversations around it
um but uh you know i'm i'm interested i
i
not only would love to revive the rule i
would love to like figure out a way to
like make a domino movie or something
like that
so um you know we'll we'll see we'll see
what happens but i i haven't had any
like personal conversations
sure my last the last subject i want to
talk to you about is something i'm
incredibly excited about which is bullet
train
um i got to talk to kelly who's david's
wife
and she's telling me some stuff uh and
about how all the action is on the train
and it's very contained and it provides
an interesting dynamic for the movie um
can you sort of talk about being a part
of bullet train
what can you say about your character
and doing the action in that film
i don't know if i can really talk about
my character but um
the the film itself is just like it's a
really fun world and it's super funny
like
honestly it was like being on that set
felt just really kind of like a breath
of fresh air in terms of like
introducing a little bit of levity into
my life and
um and i just i had a great
time doing that it almost felt like i
don't know it was just super
fun and it was about like having fun
and um um not the not the movie itself
necessarily but just like
the experience everybody wanted to like
have a good time and so
um yeah i just had to you know
i think again it's sort of this like
sort of like
heightened world in a way and um
and this sort of i don't know what i can
say or not i don't want to get you in
trouble can i can i i'm out of time but
could i ask you something different
about the movie that you want
before yeah um so one of the things that
i would imagine you grew up
and are a huge brad pitt fan so i'm just
curious
what is it like making a movie with
someone like brad pitt
and maybe what surprised you about
working with him
hmm he is um he is
lovely i had such a good time um i think
also
you know honestly i i i grew up
obviously with him like
in the film space and as somebody that i
would
like career-wise i you know i just
respect so much and he's so talented and
but then to like really see that in
front of you and to be like oh there is
a reason why you have been
so successful in your work because you
are such a natural at
a you know just being engaging and
interesting on screen and to have great
ideas
but then also he's like he's kind and
he's gentle and like he's just
fun to work with and um you know people
like i i would love to work with him
again you know and um
you know i don't know i think there's a
there's a reason why people
um you know you want to see him on
screen because he's he's good at what he
does he's just good at it to see it in
front of you i'm like wow
like i hope i can get there one day
you know just in terms of the ease of
being able to create and to think on
your feet and to
just just make great choices on camera
and he's
he's great at it so yeah david's not bad
too
um i gotta go you know uh but yeah kelly
told me
a few things and it sounds awesome yeah
you know i don't want to get you in
trouble
so anyway have fun in europe though
thank you
thank you yeah i'm excited um and nice
to see you again
nice to see you and hopefully when nine
days uh comes out we'll
talk more extensively you know about
that it's such a i hope so
yeah all right well thanks steve cool
have a great day
hi youtube